this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by liquid iv
raycon and upstart more on that later
let's get into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com
ryan sickler on all social media website
for the show is the honeydewpodcast.com
make sure you subscribe to the youtube
channel all right you're getting audio
on monday
dropping that video on tuesday all right
if you got to have more do
join the uh patreon community where
we're hearing the wildest [ __ ] i've ever
heard my i
like i knew when we cast the line out to
all y'all that we were gonna get
crazy [ __ ] but i never in my life that i
think i'd hear some of the [ __ ] i've
heard so
it's five bucks a month uh if you sign
up for the year you'll get over a month
of free episodes
it's been a lot of fun uh santa monica
music center here where i record if you
need music
instruments music lessons for you your
kids
this is the spot they have online
classes go to santa monica music dot com
use the code honeydew
they'll wave the registration fee and
they'll give you one free lesson when
you sign up
for a package all right if you are new
to the show welcome
if you're not welcome back what we do
over here as we highlight the lowlights
i always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers it is
a pleasure to bring this gentleman back
to the honeydew ladies and gentlemen
please welcome back
yada's papa's y'all there he is thank
you
to the dude what do you call them do
heads the do crew
do crew yeah yeah double dues double
dues
yeah so what's up to the crew it's good
to be back
you know it's your first time in this
studio you were in the ymh studios the
first time yeah but you know what this
one
is nice i hope you like it yeah this one
is nice
i love that you kept the colors you kept
the theme you kept the bar
table and we've added your own mugs so
you know it's nice yeah you're such a
nice dude
yeah this is great uh listen i want to i
want you to promote everything but i i
want to say
like i constantly watch your videos your
stand-up's fantastic i love seeing you
clip it out but the
the characters you're doing shirtless
and [ __ ] dude and oh god i love
derrick from florida yeah derek from
florida my brother's name is yeah
florida they're their own animal down
there yeah they are yeah they just uh
florida is just a place it's like i
realize it's kind of like america's
penis you know
if you were to do the brain the brain is
kind of like the northeast mit
new york rhode island they got rit up
there all those universities
and then you got like the middle is kind
of america's stomach
you know big stomach you know that's
where we eat that's our girth
yeah and then uh texas is the balls
right and california's kind of the
mental illness the delusion
you know what i hope the chinese storm
santa monica wouldn't that be funny
i was so that's where we are
[ __ ] we've been stormed already
but wouldn't it be great
we don't need any more movements coming
in here oh yeah yes recently you got
storm but i mean i'm talking about a
proper invasion
like you know storming the beaches in
norman that would just be hilarious
because i was looking we were driving
down the pacific ocean
and i was just looking i was like wow
china's over there yeah and i was like
wouldn't it be great if they just
[ __ ] stormed
and then they just set up like a
captain's quarters at wreath
witherspoon's house
and then they're like planned their
attack to pepperdine university and just
moved in
i just want them to storm how great
would it be if the chinese storm the
[ __ ] tick tock hype house
that would be hilarious that would be
yes i bet that place is like protected
by two three massage guys but
they would stand for a couple minutes
because mossad guys from israel they're
tough but the chinese just got the
numbers
and they they do and they may they may
send a virus first
and then do it second what i'm saying is
the chinese may be invading
now that the vaccine is here that could
have been phase one of the plan phase
two ccp
they're gonna [ __ ] invade and they're
gonna invade they want vancouver
and they want california it's closer
they're not gonna get past the midwest
they're gonna get tired walking in like
nebraska and [ __ ] ohio oh wow
they're gonna walk the wrestlers in iowa
those cornbread kids are going to
[ __ ] stop them they are good
citizens yeah you can't storm the
[ __ ] capital
well uh please promote everything you'd
like to promote here
okay i'm covered free you are yeah i'm
covered class of 2020 baby
so my graduate i haven't even mentioned
it on anywhere
yeah we can do open hand high fives yeah
there it is i had it you
talk all about it on this episode i
cough when i laugh but i've got the
antibody and i got a healthy dose of it
per my doctor me too i got my negative
test over there in the office i got my
antibody on the phone
isn't it funny when you cough now you
have to explain like people like
because when you cough you're like
that's the sour patch kid yeah you see
people just go
like i'm stuck yeah you exaggerating
about that i had it yeah when you had it
it's really it's like really this this
uh wait promote promote first we're
getting off on the cove and we're gonna
come back
i'm with you i got it um promoting uh
i got a new podcast uh i just started
called long days
it's just me ranting and it's doing real
well it's off to a great start so i want
you to check that out of course history
hyenas which i plugged last time with me
and krista stefano
check that out please watch my special
too that's still up for free on youtube
called blowing the light so check that
out and uh
yeah i just did rogan yesterday check
that episode out
this new podcast i just did um are you
garbage which you should do
i did you did it i mean how fun is
fantastic i mean i loved it
it was so much fun so that just came out
so check that [ __ ] out
and it's good to be back on the honeydew
one of my favorite people i've met in
comedy
thank you man you only really hung out
on your [ __ ] podcast that's it yeah
yeah but you're a guy
everyone's just like yeah he's just a
great guy i don't know about that you
never know how people really feel about
you but
yeah but um but we are coveted survivors
uh we're gonna share our stories here on
this episode i haven't told anybody and
i didn't
i don't know if you did and i don't have
anything i didn't make it
public on my social media or whatever
because we had a small
well you had a small crew too we had a
different small crew
why don't you uh why don't you start
yeah so it's all public people know it
again
yeah so how did it happen how did you
first find out
okay so i'll just be i'll just preface
it by going i just had a baby
congrats not me congrats i'm not trans
but boy or girl
it's a girl all right yeah but you guys
say that kelly be like did i have a baby
yeah i don't and my pronouns are he-ha
now my pronouns are he him and so i did
not have a baby my wife had a baby i
hate when people say we had a baby i
just like it just
[ __ ] bothers me after i watched my
wife deliver
i was like i did not have that baby that
baby came out she had it she had it we
have it
we have it yeah i like that she had it
yeah we have it
yeah we have a baby yeah i can't feed
that thing with my
anything on my body no yeah so that's
you know yeah i mean
we should update they shouldn't even be
called women anymore they should be
called mortal gods that's what they're
pronouncing i love that you see this
it's crazy so uh i just had a newborn so
i was kind of run down so i'll preface
it like i haven't been selena how it is
when you first have a newborn of course
we didn't sleep at all
and are you also extra scared with the
layer of you just brought a newborn
into a covered ridden world and this is
the most vulnerable
uh human on the planet right now can't
can't vaccinate can't do anything yet
yeah and
six weeks is the crucial point for the
immune system so pre-six weeks they're
very vulnerable um
and also i was fat because i was hanging
out with my pregnant wife
and we were [ __ ] you know she wanted
mozzarella sticks we ate mozzarella
sticks listen let me tell you something
you had a girl you said or boy
girl girl the thing that getting fat
helped me with is when you hold her you
can put her right there
yeah that belly pops out it's like a
little [ __ ] seat i'm telling you
mother nature wants that for you it's
wild yeah
it wants the difference that's it it's a
positive
spin on it i like it it's a seat i like
that you'll see
i'll go with that you'll see also if i
could give you any tips and here's
number one don't listen to anybody
number two don't always carry your
daughter on the same side if [ __ ] my
back up
try to try to alternate okay the whole
time you're always doing this
[ __ ] your whole [ __ ] up your whole
system's out yeah the people the advice
people gave me were like oh my god
you're never gonna sleep again it's so
hard it's like
it's hard for the women they have to
they love to do it i sleep my mother
and my i mean my wife and my
mother-in-law you know they did the they
do
most of it my mother-in-law's been
amazing helping us out
and like the baby just wants the mother
more for the first three months
oh yeah babies cause we can't do it we
can't feed it
nothing i've talked about it on my album
nothing made me feel
um less like a man than being in the
room watching
my daughter's mother deliver my daughter
me too i mean
nothing made me feel more like a [ __ ]
in my life like
what what do i even need to [ __ ] be
here for right there's nothing i can
provide i cut the cord
yeah but anyone could do that yeah i i
didn't cut the cord because i was they
asked me i was like are you kidding like
i didn't
i'm gonna i don't i don't i'm not a
professional cord cutter
that's like telling me it's like telling
me when you go to a restaurant like go
[ __ ] get your
i'm like don't you work here that's what
you do first of all they don't prepare
you for that you're gonna be part of the
delivery
they make you work yeah so if you
haven't had a kid yet just
know i held her leg
yeah he's going hold her holder and then
they and then they're like third base
coaches which is hilarious and a lot of
times
i was like an umpire back there yeah
they go come on come on i remember the
doctor was going
that's it that's the push that's the
push that's the push come on that's the
bush that's the blush
and it wouldn't be the push so i was
like doc can you stop saying that cause
you're [ __ ] with her head
that's it that's it that's it you keep
sending people around third and they're
getting easily thrown out of home
exactly he's [ __ ] sending everybody
just sending them
everybody there's not even a play at the
place i was like dude you're gonna
[ __ ]
we're all gonna lose this game stop
sending there's no it's not [ __ ]
the ball is in the catchers man that's
the push go go go go go
go go ah no i could kind of see the head
and she was going like oh my god get
this thing out of me and i'm standing
there you i'm
holding the leg i'm part of it it's
crazy
it's crazy you're part of the delivery
so you just go to work
so are you at first were you so wait i
got a lot of questions
yeah because you had corona and you have
a newborn so the new
when i got kirana she was about three
weeks old or four weeks old so it was
like
so did you leave the house so what
happened was we did a podcast me and
chris went down to do flagrant two
with uh with akash singh andrew schultz
andrew schultz
we were filling in for andrew cause
andrew was at that time
writing his netflix show and he was on a
deadline but they were all at the studio
so they were in one room right in the
netflix show
um and then we were in uh we went into
the studio
and did the show so it was me chris
akash
uh a kid from netflix to watch so we
didn't say something wild and ruined uh
andrew's deal and um which when you have
the highs
you know you're gonna have to edit with
the hyenas and then um
and then alex um schultz's producer so
there was
five of us in there guy from netflix had
it already
and chris chris is immune apparently
because chris was with a couple people
that had it
slept at their house in the car with
them
negative negative negative and he was
the only one in that room that didn't
get it
wow so i got it alex got it uh akash had
it akash got it from someone he did a
show with andrew schultz got it
marky gagnon got it um one of the
writers and one of the schultz's guys
who helped him write the show and writes
those things he's great
um and maybe a few other people got it
that i don't know about colin quinn got
it from me
damn yeah cause we had colin quinn on
the hyenas right the date the next day
and i didn't know
so because it takes a couple days and
then akash told us when he found out he
had it
so then i knew colin was gonna get it
and collins you know colin 60 at this
point 61 maybe
and he's had a heart attack so like yeah
that was also hard for me knowing that
you know that's the part the part nobody
talks about is how difficult
the isolation can be um
because you're worrying about the people
you've given it to if you know
you know and if you have a newborn i was
worried like jesus didn't give to my
newborn to give to my mother
[ __ ] what are they gonna do
they're raising a baby so it was like
you know you can't my my wife can't stop
raising the baby right they'd have to
give it to someone else i mean it was
like
a [ __ ] nightmare so uh for me
um so my situation was i
i was going to the i so i go every six
months to get physicals
my family's always had a health history
and i don't [ __ ] around so
i go in the week before i give the blood
the urine i come back
the week later they've got the results
we sit down we go over everything right
so i go in on like a monday um
and this is right at like christmas and
i
get tested and i'm negative i'm also
negative for the antibody so i haven't
had it and i don't have it
and then segura is now in like about to
get out of recovery or whatever but i
i'm like hey are you allowed to have
visitors can i come see you he's like oh
my god i'd love it
when's the last covet test you had i was
like you know a little over a week ago
and he's like well you got to have one
within like 48 hours and i was like no
problem
and i take one knowing it's going to be
negative but it's
positive i'm like no so then i think
well
there's a lot of rumors out here that
there's false positives right because i
have
no [ __ ] symptoms right so i call my
daughter's mother
and she answers the phone and i'm like
you sound like [ __ ] and she's like i
just left the kova test i'm like well
you have it and she's like how do you
know i have and i said because i have it
she's like but you don't i go
i got a positive test and you sound like
it so let's go get stella tested
so we get our daughter tested she's
positive her mom's positive we had to
get a babysitter she's positive
and then two close friends of ours
positive so there's six of us in our
inner circle that got it
and you know at this point we who the
hell knows
you know we're a split family we have to
go back and forth everyone has to work
we do
we're very diligent about masks and
washing hands and sanitizer non-stop and
um you know the doctors like ryan in la
it's one in five
it might even be worse than that by the
time this thing drops and
you know i'm like is it airborne in
these stores he's like yeah he's like
the thing is
you got tested a week ago here you have
no symptoms
you wouldn't just test yourself again a
week later you're not supposed to anyway
you're
you're clogging up the [ __ ] system so
there's
there's three to four days where you're
completely asymptomatic while you have
it
and you don't know and you're in the
grocery stores and the targets or the
wherevers
and this is the problem this is why we
need a vaccine there's not people
there's probably some [ __ ]
maliciously going out there but most
people
once they have it they realize oh [ __ ]
this has probably been in my system
three to four days and
i've been uh 800 so he's like someone
could have sneezed in the [ __ ]
grocery store and you walk into that
gets in your eyes yeah or you touch
something and just scratch your eye
boom done he's like and there's six of
you there's no way to know so
fortunately um and this is what i was
telling you
none of us ran fevers none of us had
muscle aches
none of us had um anything in our chest
right at least feeling it we'll talk
about that a little bit
um you talked a little bit to me outside
about like the gi
stuff like i had diarrhea at first but
also i was drinking this like probiotic
dairy yogurt and i was like i think it
might be that actually and as soon as i
stopped doing that
diarrhea no pain or cramper yeah so
you'd know if you had the gi version
my daughter was very mild um two days of
mild stomach aches but still eight
normal
normal energy no fever slept normal all
that
um my my friend and the
was it the sitter they
lost uh sends a smell for like three
days
and then everyone was mild i had my
daughter's mother was like the worst
down for a couple days
i had a head cold that i would put it a
four out of ten you know what i mean
like
nasal spray and i can breathe um but
after day like four
boom smell goes and taste goes i still
it's been what a month i i still don't
have smell
at all right now and i can taste it
because it just farted
you can in here because i had it i know
you told me before so i was like should
i let this go
oh yeah yeah which has been a great
thing about the mask
and like because i've been like whenever
i shop i've been crop dust and just gone
like everyone's got masks
it's almost like it's set up the world
is almost you can use your imagination
yeah like in the movie life is beautiful
where he was telling his daughter all
the funny stuff and
rearranging why they were in the
concentration camps in my mind to make
it happier i was going like everyone's
wearing masks cause i'm i fart alive so
this is
like the government was like giannis's
ass is so [ __ ] fumed out
everyone's got to put them and that made
me smile it made me happy comedy cures
everything it does
it really is a natural drug and it's
needed
i um i can tell you i can taste
sweet i can't tell you what the [ __ ] it
is but i can
tell you something sweet in my mouth i
can taste minty
and i can feel spice and heat i can't
smell a [ __ ] thing
i can't smell weed the other night i was
cleaning the bathroom good time neat
[ __ ]
not everyone's got fumes um but i'm
cleaning the bathroom and i've got
bleach and i don't have a daughter now i
got to stop with that right
listen you there's enough your
daughter's already hurt they're gonna
hear everything we've ever [ __ ] said
that's right
and use it against when i have to go in
for parent teacher conference i'm going
to
come in and be like my dad puts a wig on
and goes das say
that's his career
um oh god it's going to be but my eyes
start burning my throat starts burning
and i realize oh [ __ ] i can't smell the
bleach
and that's what's killing me in this
bathroom like holy [ __ ] so
it's you know at first i was like this
might be a false positive then i was
like oh five other people got it oh yeah
i got it and then when i lost my smell i
was like boom
so it's been um and then i told you i'm
very diligent about this [ __ ] i went and
got the antibody test i have it i got a
healthy dose of it
um but they said they did see some
nodules on my lungs and [ __ ] that might
be scarring from it so i gotta go back
in like six months to a year to see what
that's all about
i don't know when this shit's gonna come
back but i'm alive i'm well i'm right
here
i'm able to provide and i almost feel
bad
because i know there's so many people
that had this and you're going to tell
your story you were bad
and so many lives have been lost but
i asked the doctor and lana who owns the
store here
her cousin was like head of coveted
missions at ucla and we were like
if i'm like if i'm kind of bad but my
daughter is
mild can i make her more sick and she's
like nope if you all have it you have it
it's right because it's the reaction
you're immune
to what actually makes you sick is not
the virus it's the
how your body reacts to the virus the
virus wants to live
so that's why viruses mutate down to
kind of live you know they want to live
you know you got like cold viruses and
[ __ ] like that that want to live in you
the thing is this is so foreign to our
immune system we're like what the [ __ ]
is this
and that uh second wave of inflammation
for some people is really bad
so it's ironic that sometimes sometimes
people's immune systems
have a strong response and that strong
response makes you
sick right ironically sometimes yeah i
um you know i don't know whatever these
nodule scar
things are or whatever but also my
doctor was saying like
i haven't he said all but just until a
couple months ago he goes i couldn't
find a patient with corona then
seasonally
it hits and he goes now one of two
things and i'm not a conspiracy guy but
we're either calling everything corona
or
he goes i haven't had one regular case
of influenza
now we may have eradicated or at least
pushed it down
with the diligent washing of hands and
mask wearing and
and maybe that's it or maybe everyone
that's got a sniffle whatever
is called corona i don't know but um
yeah i we got we were so four of us
quarantined together
we decorated for christmas we sat there
in our night pants we [ __ ] ordered
food in
we made [ __ ] we watched every movie you
could think of i had my daughter like 10
of the 15 days
um we would wear the doctor said get out
and get vitamin d we'd put masks on and
stay away and just go get sun but i was
telling you we walked one day for like
15 minutes i came home i took a three
and a half hour nap
that takes it out of you i did dishes
and i was down for an hour and a half
but
um we would drive around at night
because we all had it we're in the car
together the windows up and we drive
around and look at christmas lights and
listen
listen covet brought your family close
it was a cove at christmas with a
covered crew
and cozy covered christmas i hate to say
that i mean we weren't feeling great but
we were like we're good people are
way worse we're fortunate and it was
also this this little like reminder that
honestly this is all you need right here
it's not about
any of these other things like your
health is literally it's everything and
especially
i bet you're sweating it uh when you got
a new
a newborn you want to be there for your
kid you know you want to see all these
moments and be a dad
and [ __ ] yeah it's gotta [ __ ] with you
because the worst part of it honestly
was
the anxiety of waking up every day is it
in my chest
right all right i'm good i'm good i'm
good today and then wake up again and we
had a little
you know marks on the wall we're banging
them out like day four day five boom
boom boom it's like jail time yeah i'm
trying to get out you know i called my
doctor and he said everybody was sort of
like you pretty mild he said he did have
a guy test
positive for 45 days yeah is that in the
gi do you have the gi version because
the gi version lingers longer it lingers
in your gi tract
they wouldn't let him go back to work
yeah as a private
so cdc says 14 days get back out there
even if you don't have smell whatever
it's not you're not
contagious but this guy had to test for
work and he said he had a patient was 45
days it took them to get uh
a negative test yeah but that whoever
that upcom have a company that is
stupid because uh that exactly yeah the
yeah you're they've they've changed it
now to seven days oh really yeah
they're the safest people we are the
safest people to be around yeah we are
the safest people here and those who've
been vaccinated
but uh they say i think it was ten and
then it was seven come out of quarantine
at ten and now they say seven
okay so they know that's when your body
generally beats it and you're not
contagious anymore or has beaten it to
the point where it's not contagious
anymore
those positive tests that that linger
for 40 days or whatever
those are usually people who have gi uh
symptoms and you know
so much i know i know everything and
some of the amount of doctors i talk to
i
have
a cousin in lowe's like one of the
greatest doctors and so it lingers but
it it comes up positive because it's
like dead basically dead virus floating
around
and the test is so sensitive that it it
picks it up
so so tell me everything that's wait can
i tell you this is so yeah so me wanting
to visit segura
is how i found out i even [ __ ] had it
or i never would have got tested until
my daughter's mother said something and
if everyone was fine
again i'm out there for a you know
whatever a week with this [ __ ]
and not even knowing it until all of a
sudden i'm like hey i can't smell
oh my god right that's that's one of the
telltale signs which i
i didn't have that you didn't my smell
was obfuscated by the pneumonia
um which because there's like you know
you got pneumonia i had double pneumonia
so
all right i'll tell the whole story the
whole story so we do the podcast
then i go home i drive home so i'm with
my daughter
without a mask so i've been exposed i
have coveted at this point
unbeknownst to me which is how everyone
is when they first got it
obviously unless you imagine having that
superpower the [ __ ] i got
um what a useless one it's good for like
one day yeah
that's your one you're like that's my
superpowers i know i have coveted
specifically
this disease that will be here for
pandemic and then be gone by vaccine
um but anyway um so
i went home i held my daughter
greatest feeling in the world obviously
three weeks old you're probably kissing
her and
mother with saliva and everything else
my wife is there
my wife uh my wife her mother we're all
there my house is not that big
i'm there then uh next day
we go uh me chris
uh our producer we go to chaz
palmitary's house
and we shoot something there uh an
episode for our history hyenas
unbeknownst to me he had it already his
son
chaz had it he's older did he do well
with it
symptoms weren't that bad he had it his
son had he's the greatest guy by the way
he had it and i'll tell you about that
afterwards he was like
talking to me on the phone and helping
me through the anxiety wow because the
anxiety stays
that's what i'm saying that anxiety plus
the level of having a newborn like oh my
god could i
kill my [ __ ] newborn child like i'm
over here just
having those feelings myself you're an
empathetic guy so a lot of people don't
get that right away but that was a big
part of what i was going through
that was like a huge part huge part of
what i was going through was
every day every minute felt like an hour
because i'm going like how's my baby
how's my baby you know how's my baby
how's my baby
and then also am i gonna see my baby
again when i started getting sick
and i got real sick so uh and then the
anxiety
compounded on top of that and then when
you go to the hospital
the way they treat you kind of is like a
soldier a little bit because they're
dealing with such
so much stuff that they and they can't
tell you you're gonna be able to
did yeah i know i'm going out of order
and everything it's okay i'm just i'm
you've
had it bad yeah so then i after that
um i go back home again so that's two
days i'm home with them when i have it
and you've been in a hospital now where
are you no no this is the beginning oh
god
i'm i'm sorry i'm going back to the
beginning after chas after we shoot with
chaz
right and they all had it or else i
would have given it all to them good
right chris again didn't get it so as
you know krista stefano my podcast
partner somehow didn't
sit next to him yeah i think he didn't
get it because he's admitted on the
podcast that he's had chlamydia a bunch
he calls himself chrissy chlamydia
so i feel like kovitz showed up but it
was like get tough
well you know when you go to an elevator
and it's packed and you're like i'll
just take the next one
yeah kovin showed up was like this one's
already full and just went to me
[Laughter]
you know in his past he's good now you
know he's got another kid on the way god
bless him but in his past
you know kids got some time yeah so
uh then uh we go the next day and shoot
an episode
in the studio our studio in brooklyn um
which is where i ended up quarantining
which also was a horror story
and we shoot it with colin quinn okay so
we shoot that episode
and then the next day we get a text from
akash going fellows i'm really sorry
you know i was feeling a little run down
like yesterday i went and got tested i
have covet
so i was like [ __ ] and i just knew you
know when you know you're like [ __ ] we
were sitting there talking in the closed
room like that's how you get it you know
that's like
why it comes on in the winter it's like
everyone's inside talk i was like [ __ ]
and we were sitting there for an
hour and a half so but i didn't feel it
yet
so i just decided uh all right i'll get
cover test tomorrow let me drive home
because
it had been a couple days so i'm like
maybe i didn't get it
you know when i get home i'm i i put a
mask on i tell my wife like yeah let me
just i didn't want to [ __ ] i was just
like let me uh
you know and then here slide that mic a
local
sorry and then and then um
whatever the timeline was and then i
take a shower
and i'm feeling like a little weird it's
a weird feeling i can't this is within
two days
this is a no this is now uh
three days okay or four days uh monday
tuesday wednesday this is three days
almost four because it's night time
of wednesday right or something so it's
a weird feeling
the first symptoms were weird it was
like a burning here like a little
burning
and then just like i'm in a dream like a
little like whoa
and then i took a shower and then i took
my temperature and when you take a hot
shower afterwards your temperature's a
little higher so it's like i was like i
think i got a 99.9 that's not a fever
right
and i take it again boom 100.7 or
something like that
and i just was like [ __ ] i'm out of here
i told them i packed
i left and i drove straight to our
studio
right because there's still a bed there
it's my old apartment so i kept it and
we just used that
so i went there and then i got a i got a
cover test in the morning
he he uh i felt fine that morning fell
fine he took my temperature when i went
to get the covey test the doctor
no fever no fever nothing i ate a bagel
appetite um took a nap i woke up saw the
text you're positive
damn i was like okay and then he's like
oh yeah you should you have a finger
thing a finger
an oxometer i was like no he's like all
right you know let's see how you feel
just tell me how your symptoms are as we
go along
first night fine i sleep fine watch some
movies
order food full appetite
fine but you're by yourself away from
your buy myself
my baby worried about that like that oh
my god
uh did i give it did i give it to them
give it to them yeah i give it to colin
and so that's when the worry starts
right so that's just anxiety yeah you're
like [ __ ] i gave it to colin [ __ ] i gave
it
i gave it to my baby i gave it to my
baby right but you knew for a fact that
you gave it to colin
i just knew that since we're sitting in
the apartment and you we
did an hour and a half it's like it's
probably we switched seats at one point
he used the microphone i couldn't see
how he wouldn't get it you make a great
point because i'm very fortunate i told
ash
our numbers were getting out of control
here and i was like look we work for
ourselves i don't want to be working
during the holidays
let's get enough episodes ahead and
we'll chill so we were able to shut this
down
and i know it didn't come out of here
which is also
pretty awesome that every person that's
come in here has been honest and
and fortunate too we're fortunate
because it could have been during that
period where they didn't even know they
had it but
not one person's had to call me and tell
me so i'm
i'm very [ __ ] lucky that's great yeah
that's great but it's also
i hear you you guys got a crowd of
people in there too
yeah we had a crowd of people in there
um and you know it's unfortunate because
that's the problem is like this is what
makes it a sophie's choice it's like we
got to make a living you know what i
mean
it's like so everyone's struggling with
this sophie's choice of like i got to
make a living but covet i don't want to
give it to anyone i don't want to get it
it is a very dangerous and unpredictable
it's russian roulette i mean that's the
it's a real thing and most people it's
mild and the symptoms mild but it's also
scary because you don't know who you
gave it to
right um and you don't know what they
don't know for sure what the long-term
effects of this thing that's right
that's what i'm waiting for yes
it doesn't seem bad the latest studies i
keep reading is like this seems like
it's okay it seems like
people who recover but there are some
long haulers and of course they're
usually older they have some
other conditions but we don't they'll
never know they'll never know for sure
until years go by so that's a whole
nother story but anyway
so i drive straight to the studio
straight to the studio
i'm you know first day second day the
only thing is the anxiety of who did i
give it to did i give it to colin did i
give it to my baby did i give it to my
wife did i give it to my mother-in-law
but you're still feeling all right still
feeling okay i'm going like this is
gonna be a breeze people are calling me
you know that a few doctors called you
know like my uh
my wife's father is a doctor he's not a
doctor in that field but he's a doctor
so he's like you know
just be careful you know this thing it's
unpredictable which made me nervous
in retrospect i wish he didn't [ __ ]
say my doctor said the same he goes
you don't want to hear it what are you
on i go like day four or five he goes
all right all right he goes well this is
where it gets tricky because
this is where it sort of can take a turn
but
i really believe that if you're only
with these symptoms right now you're
gonna probably get through with
with that and i was like [ __ ] and that's
where the mental [ __ ]
comes and exactly is that second wave
now they call of inflammation that comes
day three to seven somewhere in there
uh you know usually three four five
and that's what happened to me bang and
it's weird you wake up like that i wake
up like or it was
or it was like in the middle of the
night i woke up and the symptoms were
different like
every day every hour it was weird man so
you went from a
just a fever fever came back fever would
come back harder at night of course you
feel the fever more at night because
you're just laying there doing nothing
um and my fever was not that bad 100 101
you know uh alex the producer uh had it
um 104.
104. yeah whoa that's dangerous
yes and he had it for days so um it
started with that and then it starts
with this
i remember the back pain was like back
pain so it was like difficult to sleep
and lay down and
the ache was this back pain it's just
weird back pain then the dry mouth was
so
dry like dry and then um
and then the stomach kicked in and that
was the worst those were my main
symptoms and then the weakness fatigue
the sweating my liver enzymes for some
reason got elevated
everything yeah it attacks a lot of
different some people attack their brain
yeah and kills tissue it attacks uh you
can attack your heart
obviously attacks your lungs that's the
common one i mean i went and got a scans
and x-rays on my lungs that's how they
saw the nodules i went and got a scan on
my heart
i went and got you know gave the blood
for the test for the antibody and i got
it i
you know i i've already tested negative
as well just wanted to get that i've got
everything
you could [ __ ] have right now so yeah
but but knock on wood i mean i hear
these stories so
there's a lot of different stories i i
know someone who uh knows someone who's
paralyzed from it
they're paralyzed they don't know if
it's permanent i know someone else uh
whose doctor friend was intubated was in
the icu intubated for two months
so these these things happen it it
happens it's legit yeah
and it happens to all age conspiracy you
know it's not [ __ ]
it's just [ __ ] it's real um
and it's like mark maguire is to a
baseball player
this is to the flu yeah this is like the
flu on steroids yeah
[ __ ] barry bonds of sars and my my
doctor said look it's here to stay and i
go it is so i was asking him about that
too and he goes
well coven 19 we're going to get immune
to that but it's going to mutate like
influenza does and it's going to be
covered 22 or whatever the [ __ ] year it
is next and then we're going to need one
for that yeah and that
and that you know it's here to stay my
brother's a scientist and uh
works for the army and he makes corona
in a lab they actually
create it so he's got to know some [ __ ]
study it and he was saying that
he was just going it's a bio weapon for
by ccp
here's the thing he they got to it
before we did damn it
these [ __ ] um he really
believes how you react is strictly just
your body type
it's it like there's no like there's
rumors that what is it
uh typo is is immune
um so i don't know if that's true he's
like it's just it's what you said
it's exactly what you said it's just how
your body
handles that virus i wouldn't the
analogy for me is like it's russian
roulette with one bullet in like
a eight chamber or ten chamber gun so
would you play russian roulette if
would you spin it and do so it's like
the chances are
greatly in your favor that you're gonna
get through it and be okay
almost everyone lives ninety-nine
percent uh it's got like a one percent
mortality rate or something it's
hovering around there
um so it's this is not killing us like
the spanish flu it's not killing us
like the plague it's not killing us like
uh you know smallpox or whatever you
used to or whatever else
but history repeats itself and i'm
hoping within the next two years it's
the roaring 20s of
this generation coming out of a [ __ ]
it will be
it will be it will be we're we're about
to end that and by summer this will be
over
i believe i hope so distribution will
speed up
it'll be a combination of herd immunity
um vaccine
distribution and well this city is about
to be one of the safest places to be in
the world it's so filthy here we're all
going to have it in the next three
months is going to be the perfect time
yes
visit l.a yeah so we'll get through it
all all covered comedians come on out
and do the do when you're out here come
out
see my [ __ ] yeah people be sparking on
the street come see the show
stand up everyone's got the antibodies
you know it's called covid
covet comedians um so then yeah
so all right so then that's when it
started about 3 4
boom let's take a quick break and tell
you about our first sponsor
liquid iv now one of the goals i have
for myself this year is to stay
healthy and i will be doing that with
the help of my favorite hydration
product liquid iv with one stick of
liquid iv
and 16 ounces of water you get two to
three times the amount of hydration
as plain water liquid iv has incredible
hydration flavors like watermelon lemon
lime and passion fruit
and they recently launched strawberry
imagine a freshly
picked taste of ripe juicy strawberries
topped with decadent
notes of whipped cream now i love liquid
iv
i've been using it not only when i feel
dehydrated around the house or whatever
i pop these things in
you're listening to this episode now all
during the coronavirus i took liquid iv
i took the wellness one that had zinc it
had vitamin c
and i and absolutely helped me out it's
the perfect balance to help you hydrate
more quickly and
effectively than water alone liquid iv
is on a mission to change the world
they've already donated 4 million
servings in response to coven 19.
products are being donated to hospitals
first responders food banks veterans
and active military they've donated over
10 million servings
globally now grab your strawberry liquid
iv or their other great flavors in bulk
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
the code honeydew at checkout that's 25
off anything you order when you use my
promo code honeydew at liquid
liquidity.com
get better hydration today at
liquidive.com
code honeydew our next sponsor is
upstart now
last year showed us that you never know
what life is going to throw at you and
if you use credit cards to pay for
unexpected expenses
it can be overwhelming to manage that
debt take control
with upstart so you know exactly what to
expect upstart is the fast and easy way
to get a personal loan to pay off your
debt
all of it online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used
upstart to get a simple
fixed monthly payment i know a lot of
you are using this out there and you've
emailed me
told me how great it's been for you how
easy it was
and how easy your life is now because of
it i absolutely recommend
get it all together don't be paying
ridiculous interest rates on these
credit cards they don't deserve your
money
upstart finds smarter rates with trusted
partners because they
assess more than just your credit score
with a five-minute online rate check
you can see your rate up front for loans
from one thousand
to fifty thousand dollars you can get
approved the same day and receive funds
as fast as one business day
if debt is taking over your life it's
time to get a fresh start
with upstart find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com honeydew
that's upstart.com
honeydew do not forget to use my url to
let them know we sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided
in your loan application go to
upstart.com
honeydew our next sponsor is raycon i
don't know about you but i feel like i'm
always looking at a screen now more than
ever
and whether you're an avid news watcher
or in serious need of a distraction
unplugging yourself is easier said than
done one of my favorite ways to rest my
eyes and still get the content i'm
itching for
is by putting in my raycom wireless
earbuds and listening to something great
there's nights i lay on the couch listen
to music listen to old stand up back
when we could do that
uh everybody in the house loves these
raycons i told you before my stepson
took my other pair
won't give him back he's out there
skating with him tells me how much he
loves them
and if he comes around again and leaves
him i'm taking him so whether you're
catching up on your favorite news
podcast or binging an audio book or
powering through your workout with the
pumped up playlist
a pair of raycons in your ears can make
all the difference
all right there's no dangling wires or
stems to get in your way here
raycons come in a range of stylish
colorways but always with a comfortable
in-ear fit
for a more discreet look raycons are
built to perform anywhere and anytime
with water and sweat resistant
construction and bluetooth to pairs
quickly
and seamlessly and with enough battery
life for six hours of playtime
you can unplug for a while and the best
part is raycom makes great
sound accessible to everyone with
wireless earbuds starting at half the
price
of other premium audio brands i know a
lot of you out there using these too and
you hit me up about this
they're great i'm telling you it's worth
a shot you save so much money
you lose absolutely no quality and
raycon right now is offering 15
of all their products for my listeners
and here's what you got to do to get it
you go to buy recon dot com slash
honeydew
that's it you'll get 15 off your entire
raycon order so feel free
to grab a pair and a spare that's
fifteen percent off at buy ratecon dot
com slash honeydew
by raycon.com honeydew now
let's get back to the do now what where
are you mentally with worrying about
your daughter
horrific are you are you face timing and
just freaking out at that point i was
too sick to look at it really
it got to a point there couldn't watch
tv and concentrate i was so nauseous
i can't imagine what people got did you
throw up or any of that grew up
you did i was i couldn't get any food
down so i was throwing up just a yaki
just going ah
and nothing was coming out and yeah just
like water was coming out and then i was
sweating sweating sweating
i don't know what this sweating was
about but as part of the fever of the
disease the way my body reacted
so i was drinking water and i just the
mistake i made was i drank way too much
water and i got what they call
hypotremia which [ __ ] is that you drink
so much water you're getting no salt
because you're not eating anything
um and having diarrhea which dehydrates
you
so without the gatorade here's a tip if
you have diarrhea
like bad um drink gatorade
it just makes you safe make sure you get
that sodium make sure you get those
electrolytes which you need
i was telling you and this is not a
shameless plug but liquid iv is a
sponsor we'll sub liquidity use that
[ __ ]
and i'm telling you during that the
whole time they had
you know i thought that some i thought
they were just different flavors at
first when i first got them but when
i looked at them i was like oh this is
for energy this is for immunity so i
would take the zinc
the vitamin d um my doctor's like you
know we don't know but vitamin d
is very seems to be very important for
this but i've been taking like a super
vitamin d
where it's just one a week and my
vitamin d levels have been off the
charts
right they were all good charts he's
like hey mate he you know
my doctor's legit he's like look man he
goes why would you want to get the
vaccine i go to be protected he's like
you
what you just did what you just went
through is better than any vaccine right
because it's nature's defense but
doesn't the vaccine last like a year
like the fluid goes no he goes look i
we don't know he's like i'd love to tell
you it's an annual vaccine but
it could last three months right six
months we don't know
right so tests if you're really that
worried about it test in a few months if
you still have the antibody just wait
and then when you don't have it then get
the [ __ ] vaccine and ride it out
the last test they did at mit looks good
for people who have strong
uh antibodies which we have yes it looks
good that the
eight or nine months they still have it
so they're extrapolating for that that
maybe this will last years
and even if you don't have the
antibodies i think it's the b cells or
something that
will recognize to produce those t cells
and so they think the memory your your
immune system's memory as they call it
will be pretty good in most cases
there's a few cases not
it's just there's always there's always
exceptions but
it look it's looking good do you get any
like i know my heart's good cause i've
had every [ __ ] scan you can have ekgs
but do you get like i get these weird
like little pains that like ping through
it
probably anxiety i mean did they take a
look at your heart yeah everything's
fine but i'm saying i've heard about
palpitations and stuff with
covid and [ __ ] like that i was getting
like lightheaded when i stood up but
that's probably just getting older
or anxiety anxiety is such a big part of
this thing especially
it was the worst part we think too much
to begin with and we're in our own heads
to begin with
and we're just besides like guys like
joe rogan who can kill you with their
bare hands
and a few others we're a bunch of like
[ __ ] people
who are like you know overthink want
attention we're like little babies
so as a comedian having this that made
it worse i think too much as it is i
have an anxiety problem
as it is so this was just like holy [ __ ]
i'm worried
and then there's a thing like i don't
want to die no i know i'm not ready
to go the best thing that ever happened
to me just happened to me now you have
everything and then i'm going like
[ __ ] i'm gonna die right when i have a
baby and then when you get covered your
brain you start to [ __ ] hallucinate
because i wasn't eating
so this is the bad part of what happened
to me is i lost my
full appetite i could not eat a thing
the thought of eating disgusted me i
couldn't eat to the point
where i would order a chicken soup i
would i had to chew the chicken for like
an
like [ __ ] 10 minutes until it's like
and then i couldn't even get it i would
have to push it down with water
so that made me drink even more water
that's what gave me the hypotremia
and i'm having diarrhea and i'm not what
does type of
you do to your body so hypotremia means
the water
you're drinking too much water and
nothing else and so it dilutes the
sodium in your blood
you can't hold on to sodium it's like
you're peeing it all everything out and
it just unbalance and your sodium levels
dropped and that's where the danger to
me came
so i was really sick with the fever
which got up to 102 at some point
unbeknownst to me until i went to the
hospital i had double pneumonia the
worry and anxiety from you had double
pneumonia plus coronavirus well the
double pneumonia
pneumonia is just what pneumonia means
it's a fancy word for
inflammation and fluid in the lungs okay
so
covid causes pneumonia all right so it's
covered cause pneumonia you can have a
flu that causes pneumonia
you know bacteria could cause pneumonia
or a virus can cause pneumonia
things cause him but it's inflammation
in the chest so it's not in addition to
covet it was caused by a copy there
so uh i'm feeling weird like day six
[ __ ] weird man
like i've never felt before uh my my
brain is weird i'm calling myself
wee at this point like hallucinating and
the thing that freaked me out ryan i'll
be honest with you yeah
i call myself we which is like i guess
that's my
rocking the pronunciation you should
start i started
and that freaked me out because i'm like
i'm going like am i losing it
who are you talking to just yourself out
loud give me an example what you're
saying with the week
and and i i at this point i wasn't
looking at my phone i was too sick
every time i looked at my phone i felt
more nauseous every time i looked at
twitter and saw news it made me we got
to stop looking at this phone
yeah so i stopped looking at the phone
exactly we got to start looking at this
phone
uh we got to get some sleep cause i
wasn't sleeping like we got to get some
sleep we got to eat some
and then i'm talking to myself and then
i realized like holy [ __ ] we're
like we're social species i haven't been
around somebody and i'm sick now
five days six days with this that's what
i'm saying freak out
we were so glad we had we're able to be
around each other like why not
that makes a difference it made every
bit of difference
yeah and there's nowhere to walk right i
had no right there's equipment
everywhere so i'm getting out of bed
and i'm like walking like this just back
and forth in the hallway that that's the
only room i had
so it was a horrible place to quarantine
i'm all by myself and that was part of
it too
a lot of it was mental but then i
started to feel weird man whatever day
this was the day before
thanksgiving so this is when i was sick
around thanksgiving
also i got rogan booked um i'm supposed
to go like
the next week so i'm hoping to get
better anxious to get better to
go because it's my first time doing it
so i'm like i want to do rogue you know
it's [ __ ]
and um and then this whatever day it was
i'm calling myself we i'm [ __ ]
starting to freak out
we're gonna we gotta get better we're
gonna be doing rogue and we're gonna be
doing
this going who the [ __ ] am i talking to
who am i talking to you and then the
fear that you're losing it overcomes you
am i losing my [ __ ] mind look i have
this blood disease too where i
can't it's called factor five i'm prone
to clotting and i can't
sit for more than 90 minutes without
getting up and moving and
and so there's i can't just sleep like
that
i can't i have got to get up so i
every i would set alarms on on the alexa
and [ __ ] and get up and just
walk the house and stuff and just walk
out on the balcony and [ __ ] cause it's
all we could do so that anxiety i'm like
[ __ ]
yeah because the thing i we didn't want
any of us to have to do
was go to the hospital right we did not
because out here
is [ __ ] like a friend of mine works in
the industry and he was like look
there's plenty of [ __ ]
um ventilators i'm like could you get us
he's like i could get them for you if
you really need it but there's plenty of
them he's like the thing you don't have
are the beds
right and he said they took him to the
hospital out in like baldwin park or
wherever the hell he said it was and
they took him out back and showed him
the the freezer trucks with dead bodies
because they can't it's
it's crazy in la's like new york was
what worse
but you guys got better but because you
guys are all everyone got it there
yeah but it's it's bad now i mean i
think again it's like five percent again
or
and long island i think is ten percent
yeah it's the rates are high right now
uh i don't think it's as bad as march
was but i spoke to a doctor friend of
mine actually this morning
who works at a hospital in brooklyn and
he said um
the icu is packed he said uh the er
has plateaued so it's not good
um it's not good and um so i'm sorry
you're
we got to get better rogue against next
week yeah so i
you're a weekend now huh you're about a
week into this now you're halfway there
no i'm about day four now are you doing
it you're doing a 14 day right
uh 14 days quarantined yes yeah i mean
i'm sick
that's what it's supposed to be like 14
if you have yeah now they say
seven i can't even believe it's one day
without a fever yeah so the thing is if
you don't
if you get to day seven and you have one
day without a fever they can say you can
come out of quarantine used to be
ten right and then the quarantine period
was like 14. so now the cdc says seven
that's their
didn't know that yeah that's their new
thing but seven to ten is what they say
but sev it's but the important also is
one day without a fever
no symptoms no fever and and no symptoms
no fever without the aid of ibuprofen or
anything without the aid of
tylenol that's important to say as well
um that's what they say that's the
official cdc
um policy on it now so this was about
day
three or four um you know day before
thanksgiving and how old your daughter
you like two months
at this point she was three months yeah
yeah i got a brand name yeah
she's uh wait no she's three months now
what did i just say
she was weeks old i'm sorry she was
weeks old
so she's three weeks she'll be three
months in a couple days
god so this was now almost two months
ago so
i have a like a three four week old baby
oh baby yeah jesus
absolute newborn four weeks old the most
vulnerable person
more than senior citizens more than
anybody yeah because the
the crucial point for the baby is six
weeks where the immune system kicks in
so my nerves are through the roof man
now it's effect now i'm feeling it right
i'm thinking about it it was brutal
and i felt so sick man this is where i
got the most scared
i'm on the toilet and i feel
light-headed
weak i haven't eaten uh and then i've
never
felt what it feels like to have this low
sodium level unbeknownst to me at the
time
it feels weird and if it got any lower
i'd be in trouble and i'll explain a
second so i'm on the toilet i'm going
like something's wrong i text the doctor
i go
i think i'm going to call the ems man he
goes don't worry you know
he goes don't freak out you're anxious i
know you're you've been anxious during
this whole thing i've been texting him a
lot you know
every second i was like you know my
finger hurts so he goes
he goes it's cool he's like just
replenish what you're losing
try to get something down you know it's
hard for him to do this via text
i get it and as he was looking my eye he
was like checking my he's like tell me
to check my oxygen
and because that's where it really hurts
you is when the oxygen dips and your
lungs are [ __ ]
so my oxygen remained good so he's like
just replace the fluids because he's
thinking i'm just having diarrhea you
know
now they actually know that corona
dehydrates you so much
that it's one of the common things that
happens that your sodium levels drops
so if you have the gi version drink
[ __ ] gatorade
and just get crackers you got to get
something down
or the liquid iv but you need
electrolytes you need sodium yes you do
you need it so but i was like i just
soup broth all of it just suck it down
just get it down sooth brought chicken
soup
jewish penicillin get it down force it
down
but make sure you get it's more more if
you have diarrhea on the safe side it's
like you need
gatorade it's just to be safe just have
a gatorade
a little water a little gatorade i
didn't have any gatorade
so um i was like [ __ ] i'm calling the
empty even though he was like don't
worry i was like i feel weird i just
called him they came they checked my
numbers
so your numbers are good blood pressure
was okay um heart rate was okay whatever
so they're like you really want to go
because they're probably just going to
let you go and then they go it's up to
you
you know i would just ride it out and
one of them one of the guys was like i
had it too i was where you were i know
you feel like [ __ ] but
you know you'll be all right your
numbers are good but if you want to go
it's up to you so there was this moment
where i was like
like should i go i almost said no but i
was like so it was one of those moments
in my life where
i got lucky i could have said no
i was almost said no because the
doctor's telling me i'm
i'm going to be fine not his fault he
doesn't know i'm not drinking gatorade
we didn't specify
he's doing a million things he works at
an er
my oxygen's fine and much like these
guys also they're going like you're all
right
but both of them don't know how much
water i've been drinking they don't know
the specifics
and how little i've eaten how much
diarrhea i'm having so i just made it
this
i just said [ __ ] i just said i don't
care what it's gonna i have insurance
but i'm like i don't care
like let me just go and have them check
i just was like
i had a [ __ ] moment and that [ __ ]
moment
could have saved my life and i'm not
exaggerating because
what i found out is my sodium levels
when i got there they
they took my blood and then they were
like holy [ __ ] your sodium's real low
that's what made them do the chex x-ray
that's where they found i had double
pneumonia
um and it was kovid was causing all this
[ __ ]
but bam and you would have been staying
home dying i might i would have went
into con
when your sodium levels get very low you
you go you could go into a coma
you could die damn so one of the nurses
told me if i
didn't go to the hospital i could have
been in the icu or i could have been
dead
so uh it's scary as [ __ ] to think about
and um so it was just a decision so
my advice would be don't freak out have
the oxygen thing if your oxygen goes i
don't even know about that yeah that's a
common thing so it's like
and this is no [ __ ] what i'm saying
is all like this ain't [ __ ] i'm gonna
you're not this is the truth this is
positive of this [ __ ]
you get the oxygen monitor it's a little
finger thing you can get it on amazon
and you don't want to freak out but like
every four hours you know just check
especially if you have like a cough or
you know if you have
any trouble breathing just check and if
it's like
89 or 90 go to the er just go
because that's that's trouble if it dips
below 95 that's trouble
and um and also gatorade and [ __ ] so i
had what they call the gi version of it
which some people get these bad gi
symptoms where it gets into the gi tract
and that diarrhea dude that version is
painful
like if you get it bad like i got it is
it it's painful dude
it's like pain and cramps and like poise
you feel
poisoned your body wants to get nothing
to do with that virus it wants it out
and uh it reacts bad and the
inflammation and they're just trying to
your body's just trying to get it out
and um and you're coughing the whole
time no you threw up
you didn't have to have a cough but you
threw up i was actually
there was nothing to throw up because at
that point i i couldn't get anything
down it was all liquid
drinking soup like sipping it and like
pushing little bits of chicken down
and at this point i'm starting to get
loopy so i don't even know how to take
care of myself anymore
you know what the hundreds and i'm going
around smelling candles and weed and
bleach and i'm like i can't smell any of
it
christmas carols the only problem is
like a slight cough jingle bell
[Laughter]
you had a cozy cove at christmas so
that's the our experiences are kind of
the range of what can happen
that's right i had but look again though
i'm lucky just because you had it and
you got through it doesn't mean you're
out of the woods you're not
here's the other thing you're not
bulletproof you can still be infected
from the time you had it till the
antibodies built in your body
all right which takes about 30 days um
you know and what is it a three percent
chance or some [ __ ] like that you get it
again
or whatever yeah it's very rare but it
does happen are we immune to the new
mutated virus i don't know i look i
can't tell you i know that
i know that the vaccine looks good for
the all the strands
um so yeah so wait what okay so now
do your your wife her mom
do they ever get it they didn't get it
man and your daughter didn't get it
didn't get it
okay now with a newborn like that do
they even suggest a test or they just
suggest a monitor i don't know
i don't know what they do with did you
ever you didn't test her like
nasal swabbing no i'm sorry your wife
and her mom
negative the whole time my baby no they
didn't even test they just had no
symptoms
my wife actually i mean my mother-in-law
recently went and got a blood test and
tested for the antibodies
no antibodies so she didn't she didn't
have it so if she didn't have it
my baby and my i don't think anyone had
it they had no symptoms
the days went by you know so i was like
everyone's okay
but by day 10 if there's there's another
thing the doctors know now by day 10
if you have no new symptoms you're going
to recover oh no no no no no new
symptoms on day 10
or if you have no symptoms 10 days after
being exposed to someone
you don't have it right or if you had it
in our asymptomatic it's over
so you're good you're not you're not uh
contagious anymore day 10 for sure
they say seven if you've had it seven
day one day no fever
ten days after you've been exposed if
nothing happened you've never had it
so i knew they were good what point do
you feel
that you start to turn the corner like
roughly what day so i'm in the hospital
that's the weird thing that's what i
learned about that i was at the
beginning of the rush
so like it wasn't crowded yet but it was
starting to get i was part of that
initial rush
so this was right about before
thanksgiving this was the day before
thanksgiving went to the hospital
i spent thanksgiving in the hospital so
they kept me overnight they checked my
blood every four hours and also is your
family freaking out at home by the way
now you're in the [ __ ] hospital
little by little i was contacted i
didn't contact any of them yet because i
and i wasn't looking at my phone and i
told them
while i was getting better that i had it
and uh no no i mean your wife
they're freaking out yeah they're all
freaking out they're all freaking out
especially when i went to the hospital
they were friends that's what i'm saying
now it's getting worse obviously
so to get your sodium levels up they got
to do it slowly they can't do it quick
or else it'll shock your body
so they kept me overnight and slowly iv
dripped me with sodium
and then every four hours they took
blood took blood to measure it
and then also because of the double
ammonia they did test for the clot you
know they did
they checked for the clots they checked
to see if there was another bacterial
infection that was causing the pneumonia
or whatever else it could be
so i was good on everything and i spiked
102
there and then they were like you can go
right just and then they gave me a
wheezing for wheezing some [ __ ]
inhaler and
that was it in case you had some
wheezing never had the wheezing really
um and then i went home and i was
freaking home or to the studio back to
the studio
and i was freaking out i wanted to get
out of the studio that's when the story
gets good so i'm sorry i'm just getting
to this
point that's when it gets good so then
i'm like then i think i'm at the point
where
i ate at the hospital they gave me an
ativan which calms you down and i felt
back kind of good then i get home and i
just start freaking out again
i start freaking out i had a little more
diary had one more night of diarrhea
and then i was talking to my
cousin-in-law who's a doctor one of the
smartest guys you've ever known he's
like
when you're spasming at the end when
your asshole's just kind of like
doing this but nothing's coming out
that's usually when you're done it's got
everything out so he's like you're
probably at the end now your body needs
to recover
he said the body's good at doing one
thing at a time so it's either
fighting corona or resting but it's not
doing your body can only really do one
thing good at a time
so now a lot of people when they're
recovering they're actually recovering
from the fight the fever and all that
took all that out of your body so it's
like that's why you still feel sick it's
just your body's going like i need rest
i need to recover from this [ __ ]
so um i was still feeling [ __ ] at this
point i think a lot of it was anxiety
and just like and i was like i gotta get
out of here
i can't stay here anymore i can't see
her one more second i'm freaking out i
gotta get out of here
right i can't feel like a leper anymore
i'm alone i need to be taken care of i
can't make my own [ __ ] food i'm
ordering food
you know they're bringing me chicken
soups i still didn't have an appetite
though or even a psychological appetite
um and then now i'm scared to drink
water because like i don't want to drink
too much water interesting so i'm scared
of that so all this
that my anxiety is kicking in so i call
paul versi
who i live like very close to him and
his wife have had it his kids have had
it
so i make a plea and he's such a good
friend and his
wife he is i mean he's like my best
i mean he's like top level friend he's
like for me he's probably my best friend
now yeah he
and he's been for a while but he's up
there he's one of my best friends how do
you quantify that [ __ ] but
just what he'll do for you as a friend
so he spoke to his wife and they said
we'll take you we'll take you we'll give
you our bedroom
you can quarantine in the bedroom and
we'll be in the rest of the house
and you know they're kids and [ __ ] going
to school so it's like having someone
with corona in the house that you know
that's a
it's a big deal but i was probably done
with the corona at this point because
now we're at day
seven or eight so this is mostly anxiety
and i need to just recover from
resting i think i'm done i didn't even
have a fever before i went there
that was another reason why i was like i
think no more fever but i feel like [ __ ]
i just
psychologically gotta get out of this
[ __ ] studio i can't have corona
and be staring at the [ __ ] history
hyenas logo anymore
imagine you were sitting in here
i was like i can't look at chris
stefano's [ __ ] face for one more
second
i can't deal with this [ __ ] stupid
office brita
i don't have a kitchen in that apartment
because it was so small
it's just like it's like a wall in the
[ __ ] in the living room is the
kitchen so there's no i'm stepping over
lights and
cords i'm sick to my stomach i gotta get
the [ __ ] out of here
so i took an uber me and paul live like
an hour and a half outside of new york
city this is in brooklyn
i took an hour and a half uber and at
this point i still got the sweats
i even had like elevated liver enzymes
like
into december but every all the rest of
my blood was fine and
every symptoms were fine just these
elevated livers lingered for some reason
something pissed my
the the infection i covered like pissed
my liver off or whatever
so but it kept coming down so i drive an
hour and a half
up to paul's they put me in their room
nice thing
i take papa tylen off for whatever
reason because i think it's like gonna
help me sleep i sleep a couple hours
i wake up [ __ ] weak scared anxious i
can't get rid of it
and they were home they were home him
and his kids then they were like we got
to go to my mother's house they left so
i'm alone in the house
i'm checking my pulse my heart rate's
high tech cartridge it's like uh
over a hundred and i'm like start
freaking out so
i'm a comic i [ __ ] i call the emt
again i called it
i called ems again they take me to
another [ __ ] they take me another
ambulance you got two
yeah my wife sees it because you got to
pass my house to get to paul's house
she comes running with no shoes on no
socks
she's like that's my husband what's
going on is he okay
is he okay i'm sitting in there like
tired again they got the iv in me
they're like he's okay his heart rate's
a little high
so the whole [ __ ] we live in a small
place the whole [ __ ] town wakes up
like nobody nobody you know they're
going what the [ __ ] going on there's
an
ambulance in the verses house the verses
aren't home
you know they weren't there they weren't
even staying there they were like you
can stay here we'll go stay
so it's like and um yeah and at this
point i don't even have corona anymore
i'm just
at this point i just like to ride i
think i like the ride at this point
i just like the comfort of being around
medical professionals because i'm
anxious and uh
so they get me to the hospital and then
they do a cat scan there just to check
to see if there's clotting and i think
that's why they do the cat scan and then
they're like fine but the doctors
freaked me the [ __ ] out
the doctors when i first got in there
like yeah like what so what can we do
for you sir
and i'm like i don't like being called
sir in that i want a woman who's just
nice like a mom can i not have guys
like can i not can i not have these army
guys we're just like yeah your legs
blown off son because they they kind of
treat you like that they're like he goes
yeah it's a pandemic everyone's sick
that's what he said to me and i go
i need to be spoken too softly i'm a
comedian can i get somebody who's like a
social worker or
someone who's a little more empathetic
than this [ __ ] guy
who goes yeah man he goes he goes yeah
it's a pandemic everyone's sick
that's what we say yeah [ __ ] it's a
panda pandemic i know you're not feeling
well he's like yeah he had
he pointed to the other doctor he goes
yeah he had it he just came back 10 days
and i'm like i'm like yeah but me i just
want to feel better make me feel better
tell me i'll be done tomorrow and
they're like
it could be three weeks could be three
months so i go three months three more
months i can't take three more months of
this [ __ ] i can't feel like this for
three months
he's going all right relax we'll check
it out they don't make you feel better
they just say hey go home rest you
you'll be over they just look at your
heart they look into them you go you're
not gonna die or they don't think you're
gonna die
and they send you home but they don't
make you feel better at least me i
needed someone to go you're gonna be
okay
and this is when you're gonna be okay
and you can stay in the hospital and
we'll take care of you because you're a
[ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what i needed someone to
say that's what i was hoping someone was
gonna say
but uh they didn't do that so they
released me there and then my wife
doesn't want me to come home yet
because of the baby and everything so i
go to a hotel i sneak into a hotel and
don't tell them i got covent
or that i had coven so i almost felt
like a
french spy or something i walked in like
holding it all together
i'm having a full-blown anxiety attack
i'm tired
i'm sweating like i'm just like yeah i'm
here giannis pep
here's my driver's license i'm like
shaking i check in i have
campbell's suit my wife's bringing me
like leaving at the door
soups so for like two days right now in
my mind it is a split screen of us
driving around with christmas carols
look at the lights of you in the back of
an ambulance we should do it you're a
white [ __ ] rock
we should do a cartoon in this where
it's your story verse mine
so here are those slave bells ringling
[Laughter]
yeah we had different experiences
[Music]
[Laughter]
and then they kicked me out of the hotel
because of course i called the emt two
more times when i was there
no you did that i did i did yeah i
called him two more times
yeah i'm gonna have a hundred thousand
dollar bill
it's just i think it's a total
oh and i called them one more time in
brooklyn so two and oh it's that's the
sour patch kid that's the sorry
so i called them twice that's the call
to the emt two three four
five times total now yeah i went two
weeks
no in a couple days
i thought you meant the whole uh a
couple days yeah
the days where it was then why'd they
kick you out because i called the emts
twice
in one night at the at the hotel at this
point it just says
they just came in and they came and they
gave me my numbers they looked at my
oxygen
and they were like you seem fine you
sure you want to go but the last ones
told you that i know so i was fearful
but i kind of
didn't feel as bad as i kind of knew i'm
hey i'm
i'm not sleeping at this point i
developed this fear of sleep which was
weird
at this point i had a hunch i was with
you on that like i was scared to wake up
every day with new symptoms and [ __ ]
right chest
every [ __ ] day i was scared of that
it's scary when the doctors go we don't
know there's a lot
we don't know we just just keep resting
and what they all basically said is if
there's any new symptoms
or if you have any trouble breathing
come back to the hospital
that's all they really said they're like
there's nothing we can do for you
basically like
it's got to run its course so that's
kind of scary when you go to the
hospital and they tell you what it is
and they tell you how to cure it that's
a good so
you call the guys and they come back
again how far apart
even worse it was two women so i felt
even more like you should have felt
better yeah cause i was like can you
guys
carry me they're more uh bigger dicks
than the guys
yeah they were like you know like yeah
and they were the ones who came the
second time so they probably sent the
girls because they knew like hey these
guys called earlier in the night just go
there and [ __ ]
you know because like uh they couldn't
carry me in the stretches so they knew i
wasn't gonna go they would probably send
the ladies and [ __ ] so then the hotel
was just like you gotta get the [ __ ] out
of here for that yeah so then they
caught they
they they they they the front desk asked
the emt
as they were like what's going on there
like he's got covered so then they
called like this department of health or
whatever and they're like now
you have to stay here two more weeks no
in the room
so i'm like i gotta get out of here so i
call paul verzi again i'm like you gotta
bust me out of here
so he dr they almost didn't let him in
he just like came up to my room
i left like half the [ __ ] in the hotel
room i grabbed like two bags
he carried him and he just whisked me
out of a side exit and brought me into
uh
my wife let me stay in the basement
it's like he broke me out of jail
hustled you out of the hotel she was the
the
hotel owner was like this old indian
woman was screaming at him because
there's a small hotel up by where we
live
she's like [ __ ] screaming do you have
your credit card on following just
hitting you with those charges it hit me
i haven't even looked i'm god damn yeah
i mean this was like now
two months ago i'm probably down a
couple grand there i mean who the [ __ ]
knows
at that point i just wanted to feel
healthy again and
i tell you once i got healthy it was
sort of like my own christmas carol it
was kind of like
i made up with all my friends who i had
been addicted to or i had a fight with
i had a new uh appreciation for health
and while i was sick i was like i will
give up my entire career i'll give
anything just to feel
healthy because without health you can't
enjoy your daughter and then my family i
have a new appreciation for my family
and everything because of covid and that
scary thought i haven't told
this is what really freaked me out there
was a moment when i was feeling really
sick where i
thought this thought that i'd never
thought before which was is the only way
out of this
to feel this way is to die and that
freaked me out once i had that thought
earnestly because that's how sick i felt
like it was never gonna get better i was
like is that the way this
to end how i feel because it's never
gonna get better and that sent me for a
mental spiral too so it's like
it was really like a living hell for for
two weeks it was really bad man
so what was it like when you first got
to hold your daughter and kiss her
oh my god i cried i'll bet i cried
yeah i got back into therapy i got to
admit klonopin i got prescribed klonopin
which helped me
the first couple days i took it i went
to sleep i still sweated a lot
and then i stopped taking it after like
three days and i started to sleep and
sleeping normal again and slowly feeling
better again
it all felt good but holding my daughter
again
nothing like it was the it felt like
i mean god it's just like i won
nothing can compare to it it was like me
winning the super bowl or like
you know getting letterman like none of
that means anything
you know when you first start when
letterman was big getting a letterman or
a new face or a half hour
you know i had a half hour i remember
how that felt you can't even compare it
it's like comparing michael jordan to
someone who's a d3 basketball player
yeah i mean dude that's why nothing
means anything to me anymore except my
daughter
and my wife that's what i realized
during our corona christmas while you
were down and out
well you were you were healthy by that
because yours was thanksgiving
i was so you got to have christmas with
your your first christmas ever and we
got and that's why
look at that you missed your you missed
your daughter's first thanksgiving
yeah but you got the first christmas i
didn't it was the most special one
that was weird because my in-laws i
spent it with my in-laws then we went to
my in-laws house which was great i
recovered he's a doctor it was nice to
be around
him he sent me to his friend as a
follow-up so it was just nice to be
around a doctor
and he was telling me you're fine that
was reassuring but um
he kept saying like ah this doesn't feel
like christmas you know he everyone's
kind of negative on the corona because
we're all quarantined we didn't get to
see the whole family
and i kept going this is the best
christmas of my entire life
and it was yeah this was the best
christmas of my entire life
we didn't i didn't get to see any of my
family i didn't
you know but that i was healthy and
around my wife and my daughter
again after what i went through yeah
this will this
will be the best christmas i will have
the christmases from here on out will
all be
it's all downhill from here no it's not
i will never have a christmas as good as
that christmas you wait until your
daughter finds out about santa claus and
all that [ __ ] you never know what life's
gonna thrive
i'll ruin that i feel like he's not real
you think we're done with it we think
we're done with pandemics i don't know
yeah but i mean brother i'm glad you're
well thank you thank you for coming here
sorry i spoke so much man please this
was always here to see i wanted to get
mine out of the way at the top because i
knew it was nowhere near yours i'm sorry
that you went through that but i'm glad
you're all right we beat it
we've got the immunity we can get back
out there bro yeah let's go let's
uh let's tonkus or something i'm down we
can
um promote everything one more time
again yeah history hyenas
um long days go to
yannispappascomedy.com you can see watch
the long day's episodes uh those are my
two podcasts history
is the long days watch my special please
it's free on youtube called blowing the
light
and um and that's it man great yeah uh
thank you all for tuning in as always
ryan sickler.com ryan sickle on all
social media we'll talk to you all next
[Music]
week
[Music]
you